حسنًا، تواصل وكالة ناسا دفع
حدود التكنولوجيا هذه المرة حيث
ترسل مقطع فيديو من الفضاء السحيق
على بعد 19 مليون ميل تقريبًا إلى الأرض
باستخدام الليزر ويلتقي نجم هذا الفيديو
مع القطة تيس،
يُظهر الفيديو فائق الدقة القطة وهي تطارد
النقطة من  مؤشر الليزر ليس
مثيرا للغاية بالطبع لكن أه الوعد بهذه
التكنولوجيا بالتأكيد هو
المسافة بين المركبة الفضائية التي
بثت ذلك الفيديو والمرصد في
كاليفورنيا الذي استقبله حوالي 80
ضعف المسافة بين الأرض
والقمر ووصول ذلك الليزر إلى
الأرض  في أقل من دقيقتين،
تعتقد ناسا أن هذه التكنولوجيا يمكن أن تساعد في دفع
حدود استكشاف الفضاء من خلال
القدرة على إرسال البيانات والصور ومقاطع الفيديو بسرعة